[Music]
Marv Albert levy in case you didn't know
Marv was part of this you've been
reminded three times in 50 seconds
people clap before this dude shows any
ability to fly that's some Armenian guy
with a did we need to know the guy was
Armenian this movie is racist this is
the opening title or did the crazy
flying person just coincidentally land
on a taxi that just so happened to have
secured the license plate kick-ass
before anyone else I mean do they even
let you put vanity plates on a taxi why
does he own so many fucking lamps this
guy best friend Todd is only barely
winning out over hilarious animal video
on YouTube no it's not Katie's eyes are
clearly not looking at Erica when she
says hey gorgeous
also nerd things hot girl is greeting
him when she's really greeting somebody
behind him cliche product placement out
the ass
hey my knees will call this movie kiss
ass also in this orgy of product
placement how did honey puffs and clover
milk get better visibility than minute
mate which is owned by coke we see
someone too much narration the first
time we see Dave's desk the bulletin
board above it is centered but then
later its way off to the side so why'd
he pull his desk way out from the wall
was it just to allow the director or the
DP access behind the desk so they could
get this shot optimism and naivety well
I believe it's pronounced naivete which
is part of why I tried and never say
that word wait did the scuba outfit
store also make the mask and if they did
why is there any mystery at all later in
the film as to who kick-ass really is
since this company would easily be able
to spot their products and pull the
address yeah I mean bad guys only ever
shoot at the chest anyway never the
unprotected areas kick-ass gets stabbed
and falls down right here and you can
see the spaghetti sign behind him but
then in the next shot he stands up and
is miraculously 30 feet further down the
parking lot again is this movie telling
us that later on when kick-ass is making
the news that these two EMTs would
somehow not remember taking the exact
same outfit off this stabbing victim
what the fuck is all the on the kitchen
counter and who needs that many King
apples John woos first full-length
future couldn't the question a bit about
faceoff I would even have accepted
Windtalkers and since the Antony Butler
is in this I'd even take an ironic
our target questions the Oreos teleport
from the tray to the end table without
anyone touching them same footage of
outside of the school used again for a
scene several weeks later unless all
these soccer chicks are out here in full
uniform every damn day of school and
this group of gossipy girls is always
standing here in the same outfit every
morning to chat oh and blue shirt guy so
yeah same footage reused kind of asshole
takes the whole flyer instead of just
one of the phone number tabs kick
asshole that's who ruffles to for six
bucks in a convenience store no no way
man despite the fact that kick-ass has
been a major annoyance all three thugs
go back to beating up the other guy
kick-ass is MySpace
it might be OK for Tony Stark in 2008 to
think people still use myspace but it's
completely unacceptable for anyone in
2010 to use it as their chief social
media outlet Dee puts on his costume to
answer kick-ass emails kick-ass refers
to Gloria as dude dave only has Apple
updates at his RSS feed here supposed to
be seriously this guy has over 20
million views on YouTube and is on every
TV station in the country and the human
beatbox here has never seen him without
checking with a resume first the guard
allows a guy in a costume to enter the
crime den stay away from Katy now
okay so Katy said she talked to this guy
rasool and that his story broke her
heart but she didn't say anything about
him being a problem then he was hurting
her or anything now all the sudden Dane
wants to give warnings to this dude so
what Jesus anyone in this crime den have
a fucking gun Budweiser box with
solitary Budweiser can in it for
decoration I guess and well now the
Budweiser cans gone seriously not one
gun also this guy is discount
younger-looking Hugo Weaving
you can see the fat man open the door in
this shot before actually opening the
door in the shot now the Budweiser cane
is back a rerouted your IP address
finding you was way too easy it seems
like several internet nerds and the
police would have already found Dave if
it was that easy for big day and it's
been a whole week since I've heard from
Rizzo did we ever figure out what Brazil
did to Katy no okay just checking
important character backstory delivered
via another character reading a comic
book about a cliche so why are the
badges so huge look at the fact that a
comic-book coffee shop hybrid would
almost certainly never work in any city
let alone be hip and happening and
really successful the real sin is that
such a utopian place would constantly be
playing the news on their flat-screen TV
the TV the new superhero guy how cool is
that the news is conveniently rerunning
the new superhero report Katie was just
so excited about it the very second she
mentions it no one in all of New York
City had taken the license plate red
mist yet like not even a gynaecologist
kick-ass doesn't notice red mist
obviously send an on our way message to
Mikey not some chick who emailed him the
thumbnails for Chris's peeping videos
leave too much to the imagination and
the contain no lap dances when redness
plugs it in the video from the teddy
bear cam picks up exactly where the
viewers knowledge of the warehouse did
instead of you know right when he set it
there and turned it on hours earlier I
want this place locked down nobody comes
in nobody goes out until somebody finds
this cocksucker palace someone's
supposed to do that when you just
ordered a lockdown superhero holds his
own mask while contemplating appreciate
mirror to clearly opposite the window
but she never sees him once while he's
coming in the window and walking towards
her okay other movies take note lap
dance not a sin lap dance plus
intercourse way not a sin what do you
think they can help us so while in the
car with the red mist kick-ass edited
his MySpace page by placing a banner
graphic over top the entire profile all
with an iPhone Lord of the Rings music
[Music]
this kind of beating would definitely
kill him metal plates and all or find
out what happened on loss sorry Dave it
was pretty much like what you're going
through right now the heads-up display
says infrared enabled but this is
actually night-vision this gun isn't
pointed at the dudes head but that's
what explodes when she shoots it hours
later after the kidnapping the torture
the rescue in the melodramatic drive
home the marshmallows still haven't
melted into the cocoa the entire world
saw a little girl kill all the bad guys
and rescue kick-ass before shutting off
the webcam but a few hours later
D'Amico's henchmen aren't the least bit
suspicious of a little girl arriving at
the building he owns didn't she have a
gun like right before she came up here
did she switched a knife because it
looks cool yeah you're right this is the
best time to pull out the guns not
before when it was clearly a knife job
ah no no one in the building or in New
York takes notice of the machine gunfire
happening in plain sight above the city
or the bazooka blast that happened later
visionary action director rips off the
two fighters knock each other out at the
same exact time thing from Rocking this
guy is a kung-fu master who just beat
this girl's ass but in order to kill her
he decides he needs to stock over to the
gun on the other side of the room on the
floor and then he takes a few seconds to
monologue this we saved the day music is
so 90s it might as well be from an
episode of quantum leap
mimicry an eleven-year-old Mindy
Macready a so Roger Clemens has to be
around here somewhere rent superhero
movie based on a comic book doesn't have
an end credits scene one last time guys
Marv remember that name
we have to go back mm-hmm everyone
definitely his brains out if I got the
chance kids I'm gonna tell you an
incredible story the story of How I Met
Your Mother
[Music]
that wasn't flying that was falling with
style
where's Dave